six vegans one meat-eater are you able
to spot which one it is we're doing
another Jubilee odd man out
I freaking love these I and I think this
topic should be interesting
a lot of you guys commented telling me
to look at this one so I'm really
curious what this is about what's your
favorite candy most candies without
gelatin in it it's gonna be good beggin
I am vegan vegan
no one's shocked one if the group
discovers who the liar is they'll split
a cash prize if the liar survives he or
she wins the entire prize
these are always impossible do they ever
succeed in these I don't know way too
good at lying man okay Brandon what do
you eat for breakfast I'm so surprised
that she started this morning I had buck
wheat buckwheat hot cereal add almond
milk and some water okay who eats
buckwheat in the morning like I know
buckwheat not vegan enough why she's
singling out Brandon Brandon Brandon
what is your problem
but I'm looking at him and his body
language and how he's telling me and I'm
going you just had [ __ ] we are you
buckwheat you said [ __ ] we I don't know
buckwheat is that looks like cereal food
looks like a healthy breakfast that's a
normal thing but everyone acted like it
was really thing I'll be honest I
everything I'm bread I have to because
like I just like I'm a recent vegan I've
been vegan for like five months it's a
challenge I did for myself I have a
question oh my god that story was so
interesting that they just cut to
anything else
I made the challenge for myself it's uh
no one cares what do you mean you eat
everything a bread what is that what
does that mean
I ate everything I'm right it sounds
like really unhealthy vegan what are
ya'lls favorite restaurants you guys
check out in North Hollywood this is
just like awesome
is casian vegan why is this funny I
don't even care who the mole is this is
funny looking at vegans in one room I
don't know why what's comedic about it
it just feels funny what's your favorite
restaurant oh my god I love that one yes
you do I really been taking I talk I
took my friend Hannah she's actually a
big youtuber as well Oh cringe dude what
happened to this guy he was so smooth
last episode he's actually big youtuber
too I'm also big youtuber as well
large vegan also everything that came
out of his mouth was super random it's
good for Brandon Brandon but to you I
gonna talk about all the time
what are you gonna talk with what I get
a contract but swap out the beef and get
some beans in there also swap out the
sour cream and the cheese nice very like
in their rap I hope you don't use eggs
in their rap do your brand hmm some
people do that you know some use eggs
you wouldn't punish this is the most
passive-aggressive thing I've ever seen
they don't I hope they don't because I
hope those people because then that
wouldn't be vegan would it Brandon and
be vegan I don't know it's like the way
I look I don't look like a vegan why is
everyone here at vegan I was like
alright if I mess up I can keep on doing
it so I challenge myself on five months
in and I was like alright I'm making tea
no one cares no I get because it can't
speak got it oh god I can't wait to read
the comments about her we got it we
understand your life story you're a
vegan you were completely changed Alvin
was just taking up all the time so that
I couldn't find any information about
anybody I'm vegan because of the
environment I think the meat and dairy
industry just contributes way too much
to
our environmental issues and so that's
why I decided to go vegan
saving the planet amazing you know there
are good reasons to go vegan but it's
always this one person that ruins it for
everyone all the time to be afraid I
felt like a rehearsed answer almost like
that I kind of followed like blogs and
stuff and then I found out I had like
high cholesterol I like cold turkey just
like put it the more I learned about it
and educated myself the more I wanted to
keep going I initially that feels like
more of a natural sort of answer she's
definitely not in I think vegan for my
health and I don't think Brett I think
Brian is definitely vegan as well it's
kind of helped it hasn't helped that
much but I think just when I was doing
it I was like why go back right like
you're I could do it and don't worry
about I don't think there was a huge
like pressing environmental factor just
like my god she's dying right now
so why exactly go back and it's like
good so it's almost been like a year so
Kirsten where do you it smells like
everyone's just like yeah no one cares
about them all it's just so weird I
became vegan for animal cruelty reasons
it's a whole bunch of stuff you know you
can go into but yeah for animal reasons
and environmental reasons and health
reasons cool see that should be the
normal answer and then you have people
like this vegan for almost ten years
combined started off when I was 21 years
old I was drinking heavily and I just
wanted to be feeling like better in my
body so took a yoga class when if he can
over and I went raw vegan for two years
I became a raw food chef I'm a yoga
teacher now yeah yoga teacher yeah I'm a
yo Brandon eats buckwheat can you
believe this guy and he was like a
buckwheat buckwheat buckwheat you're not
raw vegan and kinda has like a
transition I was pescetarian for ten
years what is your favorite documentary
Oh helped you go with that Oh help me go
vegan I kind of watch like those YouTube
one which one like what what name one I
don't remember the names I like saw them
in the blogs that I was talking about
and like which blog um it was called it
was like this girl her name is Emma I
gave it
it's very specific yeah no she's gonna
go out for that you know it but I don't
think she's the mole that's funny I know
they're supposed to find the mole but it
just she comes across as so aggressive
about it you don't know what blog you
don't know what post you don't know this
you don't know you don't know anything
I watched the VR this actually helped
encourage me and I watched um from a
first-person perspective yeah cows
getting butchered from you could see
them getting cut up she had a little
more makeup on and she had nail polish
on and so I guess in my head I think
vegans just go further more natural look
what she doesn't have that much makeup
look and like what people were wearing
and he was wearing like suede shoes most
like vegans don't really wear leather
Brett is this a chill guy he's gonna get
eliminated for Big Joe I was really
doing I knew it a little bit shy in the
beginning when Aaron was curling me um I
just got really nervous and like I
forgot the names of everything and I put
a uniform on her she fit right in you
know which one like those cameras here
and like everyone's watching me like the
time is ticking and what is your
favorite soap I use I don't know okay I
couldn't tell you a single soap bread
I'm more vegan for like food related
reasons right but typically like if
you're vegan you use all your hi right
but like see she doesn't care about
fighting who's that they're wrong why
she just wanna grill Brandon I love it I
surprised vegan but I do it more so for
food related reason not exactly because
I'd like did it for my health
yeah can you wear a leather
I don't know mother it's interesting I
own leather didn't the other girl said
that she's where he's wearing leather
shoes liar it's him we're gonna be funny
what's her name that green wouldn't be
fun if she's the mole that'd be so good
my mind would be completely blown I
would quit I would question everything
I'd be like well now anything can be
real now ghosts can be real I mean if
she's like oh really many questions - oh
my god shut that sure yeah I I don't I
just don't oh my god what happened to
him he seemed so cool the other episode
no one cares about our name no one cares
about bees I refuse to believe people
care about bees okay
I know allegations for this I don't care
shut the [ __ ] up you don't care about
bees you don't no one does I don't care
to be fairy I hear they make honey
supplement now that tastes just like
real honey so good I just don't care
about bees I don't care about bees I
will never give a [ __ ] about bees bees I
know they're important though but I
don't care about their feelings if bees
are happy I don't give up it'd be so sad
I don't give up at all I honey good good
Brandon you should I think yeah I mean
we know you know okay I wanna okay I
wanna I wanna try and educate myself why
not eat honey all right
why not what's a good reason all right
we got Peeta here all right it's not
unusual for lottery honey producers to
cut up the Queen's bees wings so that
she can't leave the colony or to hat
okay that's kind of messed up have her
artificially inseminated on a bee sized
version she surprised that's I don't
care it's beat me feel like my reason
for being a vegan wasn't good enough
because it wasn't coming from the same
place that they were I have a question
yeah so okay everyone think about the
immediate circle how many folks in your
circle are vegan I'm supported can you
just say bye-bye my circle yeah like
they thought I was unhealthy after
what is he acting like he's made
the most important decision ever so far
you've said that you don't really
consider yourself vegan the products you
use like eight months actually he's not
into the idea he didn't mention that he
said that he got the taco and he removed
everything and my dog she's so
insufferable she's trying to be like you
actually heard that part it's vegan no
you mentioned that later on I have seen
vegan youtubers who like go to talk you
can make it just to show people that
like it can be like convenience I don't
know why you guys are you trying to tell
me level 200 insufferable vegan about
what isn't or is why don't you go there
I thought it was pretty aggressive
what's your favorite candy favorite
candy I thought they were I mean I write
you here not a vegan I mean I don't
think am I wrong here I mean listen I
don't care
you can call himself whatever you want
but you eat gelatin that's seen every
candy ever you should know that you
should know that come on
I don't care I'm just saying but you eat
honey I mean I don't care
see oh my god I'm doing the vegan thing
I'm policing that's not what it's about
read what you're what's inside your food
read the packaging okay you'll be
surprised every candy does it's really
annoying I don't get why I guess it's
cheaper to use gelatin but I don't I
wish people would stop maybe I'm not a
vegan I exactly what you're faking
I don't eat candy yeah I don't
yeah I hate fun yep
Brandon's out for sure but it's not
brand don't go after Brandon everything
surrounding you matches that either one
of these these two are definitely beigan
I feel like it's him they always go in
here I think they might okay that
explains why he was so annoying my god
they don't this all makes perfect sense
that it's been scientifically proven
vegans are more annoying
he went from a cool funny interesting
guy to holding hey can you stop talking
literally whispered to Aaron I think is
jaylen I think it's June I'm a little
mad if I go first I can speak the most
oh that's funny he seemed like she was
he was caught up on time there right now
so it'd be like it nice brother would
that annoyed me yeah look so you work me
aside started talking everything smart I
got one from my fam
okay that's not vegan I'm caught up with
her like on that one at least
why is Aaron always aiming at bread no
Aaron so rude she's so rude everyone
hates her oh I'm so surprised I'm
surprised how many people sided with
Brandon I like there are so many people
like this errand girl that just makes it
so one owing to be vegan I know people
that don't even want to talk about being
vegan because if they're youtuber
everyone on you basically open yourself
up to the
Internet I'm becoming like a target of
the police what was that in that video
huh who was doing that who was eating
that thing it just becomes ridiculous
when truth be told there are a lot of
benefits from being vegan I wish people
will focus that more on instead of just
policing each other about it especially
the environment could benefit a lot for
it especially the king bat eating would
be great how about that it we things
could be different
who eats buckwheat in the morning like I
know people do but she went after him
right away what's your favorite TV show
the oppan that's not all so finally what
you eat is not a personality no one
cares
thank you for watching smash I could be
in joining one more of these I'm not
sponsored by your blade but I just enjoy
these so check them out as well if you
want to and that's it see you tomorrow
guys Hado you know what's big peepees do
they play PewDiePie's pixel ings of
course pixel ings is a creature
collecting game I'm the primary
shareholder over a bazillion players
have downloaded and it's got a perfect
score it's safe to say it's the most
popular game of all time
PewDiePie pixel aims it's awesome deal
with it build with it
you
[Music]